الاخبار العاجله التي تتابعها فقد اشارت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه لتفعيل لمنظومه
القبه الحديديه لاعتراض صاروخ اطلق على
الارجح من لبنان وقال مراسل الجزيره ان
القبه الحديديه اطلقت او اطلقت صاروخين
باتجاه هدف فوق الجليل الغربي من جبل
الزيتون متابعه لهذا التطور مع نعود الى
نجوان
من تفاصيل اكثر من الجانب الاسرائيلي عن
اطلاق القبه الحديديه وعن هذا الصاروخ
الذي قيل بانه جاء من الجانب اللبناني
نعم في هذه اللحظات عبد القادر صدر هذا
البيان عن الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
بانه استكمالا للبلاغ الاول بيدوي صافرات
انذار في منطقه مستوطنه شلومي في القطاع
الغربي من الحدود مع لبنان في منطقه
الجليل الغربي تم رصد اطلاق قذيفه صاروخيه
اطلقت من لبنان تجاه المناطق الاسرائيليه
وتم اعتراضها بنجاح من قبل منظومه القبه
الحديديه من قبل الدفاعات الجويه لسلاح
الاسرائيلي اذا هذا هو البيان الذي صدر
الان من قبل الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
وهو يؤكد بان هناك اطلاق لقذيفه صاروخيه
اطلقت من الجانب اللبناني باتجاه المناطق
الاسرائيليه
وتم اعتراضها من قبل منظومات الدفاعات
الجويه هذا بحسب البيان الذي صدر للتو من
الناطق العسكري قبل قليل كان قد اعلن عن
صافرات انذار القوات في هذه المناطق في
منطقه الجليل الغربي
تحديدا في مستوطنه شلومي وبيتست في هذه
المناطق المحاذيه للحدود او القريبه من
الحدود مع لبنان في القطاع الغربي من
الحدود وكان هناك شهود عيان بحسب ما افاد
افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه في تلك
المناطق يتحدثون عن سماع ذوي انفجارات
بشكل متتالي والان بحسب هذا البيان للجيش
الاسرائيلي فانه كانت انفجارات الاعتراض
صاروخ اطلق من لبنان كان في البدايه هناك
محاوله للفحص فيما اذا كانت مسيره قد
اطلقت من الجانب اللبناني كما يكرر في
الايام الاخيره الماضيه فقط يوم امس اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه اسقط مسيره عند
الحدود الشماليه ولكن الان بحسب البيان
يتضح بانها بانه صاروخ قذيفه اطلقت من
الجانب اللبناني وتم اعتراضها حاليا
بطبيعه الحال ما يجري انه يبدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي بفحص مصدر هذه القذيفه عاده
يكون الفحص الاول فيما اذا كان حزب الله
اللبناني هو المسؤول عن اطلاق هذه القذيفه
ولكن في الاونه الاخيره كان عاده يتم
الاعلان بان فصائل فلسطينيه من لبنان تقوم
باطلاق هذه القذائف وبطبيعه الحال تختلف
الحسابات بالنسبه لاسرائيل
عندما يتضح من هو المسؤول عن اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ هذا يحدث واسطه استنفار امني
كبير لاسرائيل ايضا على الحدود الشماليه
سواء كان في الجولان السوري المحتل ولكن
ايضا على الحدود مع لبنان الى جانب
الاستنفار على الحدود مع غزه وفي داخل
فلسطين في القدس وفي الضفه الغربيه لكن
منذ
كانت هناك مسيره اخرى اسقطت مطلع الاسبوع
في منطقه
الجولان السوري المحتل شمالا مدينه طبريه
وكانت هناك قلق ومخاوف لدى الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه وكانت ترجيحات صدرت
لاحقا عند الجيش الاسرائيلي بان مصدر هذه
المسيره هو من ايران ولذلك تم استنفار
المقاتلات الحربيه
وكان هناك متابعه ورصد من قبل وحده
المراقبه التابعه لسلاح الاسرائيلي لما قد
يحدث في الايام
الحاليه وذلك بسبب الغارات المتتاليه التي
شنتها اسرائيل في الايام الاخيره الماضيه
في منطقه دمشق ومناطق اخرى في الاراضي
السوريه ربما وصفته بالاهداف الايرانيه من
جبل الزيتون في القدس